des enfants des milliers d'enfants dans
ces bâtiments
les enfants qui seront la population le
demain et qui vivent en circuit fermé de
l'école à la maison des gosses qui
jouent sur le trottoir qui deviennent un
problème le problème des vaincus par les
parents et les éducateurs au cours d'un
colloque sur l'enfant dans la cité et
les avait mis il ya quelques temps de
cela un règne monsieur vers prat ces
problèmes qu'elle soutient les problèmes
énormes des problèmes d'espacé pour même
d'écoles des problèmes de liaison avec
les parents tout le monde est un peu
dirais pas désarçonné 8 malgré tout
inquiet devant cette masse d'enfants
qu'il faut bien intégrer progressivement
à la cité entrevoyez-vous quelques
solutions à plus ou moins long terme
pour elle c'est peut-être difficile mais
nous sommes déjà affrontés au problème
des espaces des espaces de jeux pour
enfants dans certains quartiers ils ont
été réglés dans d'autres comme la jud
sud il faut bien maintenant les aborder
si on le veut ces espaces il existe
lorsque les immeubles ne sont pas tous
construits il reste des terrains vagues
tout autour mais après il ne reste que
la rue où le trottoir seulement à cause
des voitures et des gosses inoccupés y
traînent des gosses que certaines
organisations essaie d'occuper comme le
scoutisme par exemple
la proposition qui est faite par le
scoutisme nous permet de les occuper
pendant la période où ils sont libres et
jusqu'à présent c'est surtout le jeudi
après midi et quelques week-ends de
l'année qui nous préoccupe
et puis il ya le moment fort le moment
fort de l'année qui est le quand le
quand de grandes vacances parfois
précédées d'un gant à pâques
un camp qui leur permet de vivre
pleinement la proposition qui leur est
faite
il est donc ses enfants à l'école ses
enfants chez eux
et puis les mêmes enfants qui se
cotisent mais en dehors de ça est ce
qu'il reste encore du temps du temps
suffisamment pour pouvoir ils ont les
moyens c'est bien sûr c'est là notre
problème en fait ce serait de pouvoir
les occuper pendant tout le temps qu'ils
sont libres tout le temps les journaux
pendant qu'ils ne sont pas ni à l'école
ni à la famille mais ce temps est long
et en réalité nous n'avons pas les
possibilités n'ont pas les moyens de
leur offrir de vacances perpétuelles
déplaisir des loisirs perpétuelle
qu'entendez vous par les moyens mais et
les moyens il y a les moyens matériels
les piliers les moyens encadrent il faut
des chefs il fauté animateurs et nous
n'avons pas toujours la possibilité de
demander à des jeunes de 18 19 ans qui
ont leur vie à eux d'être suffisamment
libre pour occuper les loisirs des plus
jeunes
il serait faux de dire que rien n'existe
vous l'avez vu mais des moyens matériels
ne sont rien sans les bonnes volontés et
les bonnes volontés commence à se
développer dès l'enfance
monsieur elliott
ces adolescents que vous occupez mais
est ce que le fait de me trouver
directement avec des adolescents dont le
principe a également des problèmes ces
adolescents sont ils préparés à la vie
en société
il est bien certain que le problème de
les adolescents voient dans une certaine
mesure est préparée au stade de
l'enfance
il est bien certain que nous avons
constaté au stade de l'adolescence que
les enfants qui étaient mal préparées
qui était qui n'avait participé à aucune
action collective
vous avez un certain nombre de
difficultés au ca de l'adolescence il
restait des consommateurs et non des
participants dans les associations
en fait que leur at il manqué au stade
de l'enfance je crois qu'il aura manqué
au stade de l'enfance un certain nombre
de deux moyens en particulier je crois
que tout n'a pas été fait dans ce
domaine c'est l'ouverture peut-être un
peu plus large de centres aérés
c'est l'ouverture un peu plus large de
des associations qui pratiquent sur le
plan local une ouverture plus grande
vers un certain nombre d'autres
activités tu roulais pour résumer je
crois que dans une ville comme rennes on
a fait énormément de choses pour
l'enfance aux états intéressés seulement
notre inquiétude à nous associations à
nos mouvements
c'est de rendre compte qu'en définitive
lorsque nous nous promenons dans les
rues de rennes nous nous apercevons
qu'un certain nombre d'heures d'enfants
breizh a joué dans les couloirs reste à
jouer sur les terrains vagues presque à
jouer dans les halls d'immeubles et les
problèmes que nous nous posons à partir
de ce moment là quels sont les problèmes
qui les rebute alors qu' un certain
nombre de l'association travaille sur
les quartiers
alors qu'un certain nombre de mouvements
travail dans cette ville de rennes pour
l'enfance quels sont les problèmes qui
empêchent les enfants de participer à ce
type d'organisation
peut-être la multiplication des grandes
cités où personne ne se connaît
peut-être également le manque de
conscience communautaire et puis il faut
parler également la terre si ch'est
qu'il est dieu a ajouté au parking un
bac à sable et des balançoires
heureusement il reste le trottoir pour y
faire de la bicyclette